Hold up!
Before we go any further, make sure you’ve
watched our previous three videos on the epic
saga of Pietro Wilson and SCP - 5000 - The
Suit.
What we’re talking about here probably won’t
make much sense if you don’t.
Go ahead, we’ll wait…
Okay?
Good.
Last time we left Pietro Wilson, he was dead...and
also, somehow, alive.
It seemed that, in the last moments of his
life, Wilson left a kind of nightmare dimension
where the SCP Foundation had become evil,
and was transported back to our world as a
corpse in the broken SCP - 5000.
But is that really the case?
The fact is, the tale of Pietro Wilson and
SCP - 5000 is one of the most complex and
mysterious events in the SCP universe.
You’ve got questions, and we’ve got answers
- Why Pietro?
What was in the briefcase?
What exactly happened at the end of the story?
And perhaps most importantly of all, why did
the SCP Foundation abandon their mission,
and make destroying all of humanity their
new primary directive?
Whenever you’re dealing with splintered
realities and mind-melting nightmares, there’s
bound to be a number of interpretations.
And we’re eager to explain one of the more
popular ones right here.
Soon, you’ll know it all - but to find out,
we need to start at the beginning.
Our hero, Foundation employee Pietro Wilson,
was going about his day at Exclusionary Site-06.
However, normal operations were interrupted
when a Mobile Task Force turned Foundation
Hit Squad stormed in and began executing employees
left and right as part of their wider plan
to wipe out humanity.
Pietro got lucky though, and managed to find
SCP - 5000, making him undetectable to the
invading MTF squad.
This brings us to our first questions: Why
Pietro?
And how does killing Foundation staff help
advance the O5 council’s goal of overthrowing
humanity?
The answer to both questions has everything
to do with the site that Pietro and his coworkers
were at when the attack went down - Exclusionary
Site-06.
Exclusionary Sites are a very special kind
of Foundation site that utilizes the same
technology as the Scranton Box - a container
used to protect important items from reality
warpers - but on a far more ambitious scale.
Because of the use of this technology, these
Exclusionary Sites are essentially resistant
to CK-Class Restructuring Scenarios and Temporal
Anomalies, those are where reality and or
history itself are changed by a powerful entity.
This makes them a perfect location for, say,
staff wanting to stage a revolt when their
leaders have decided to wipe out humanity.
The Foundation wished to eliminate the personnel
stationed at these protected sites as a precautionary
measure, before moving onto the main phase
of their plan.
But this attack was just one part of the Foundation’s
wider scheme to purge their ranks of dissenters
before putting their final mission into place.
In order to make sure there were no internal
threats left who could pose a threat to the
new main directive, the Foundation murdered
all the staff at Exclusionary Sites, hunted
down and assassinated any resigned employees,
and killed off any humanoid or human-sympathetic
SCPs, leaving no one who could stop them.
Or at least they thought there was no one
left…
While all of this was happening, Pietro suited
up and exited the site.
So, why Pietro?
Because he got lucky, and he happened to stumble
upon SCP - 5000.
He wasn’t the Chosen One, nor was he in
any way exceptional, beyond his willingness
to see his quest for answers through to the
bitter end.
Pietro really could have been any of us if
we were in his situation.
When Pietro escaped, he found the world in
disarray.
SCPs had been released on a global scale - destroying
infrastructure, massacring civilians, and
assassinating key political figures.
The Foundation had even gone public, for the
first time ever, with their new intentions:
Destroy all humans.
Pietro decided to head to Site-19 and get
to the bottom of their madness.
On his way there, he saw a group of Mobile
Task Force members, performing a bizarre stabbing
ritual to see who among them could feel pain.
Remember this, it’ll be important later.
Like a lot of small moments in the story of
SCP - 5000, these are puzzle pieces that can
be fit together to create the true picture
of what’s happening out of the chaos.
At Site-19, among the dead-eyed Foundation
workers plotting mass killings, Pietro found
a treasure trove of vital information.
There he learned about the existence of Project
PNEUMA, an O5 Council-approved initiative
to map out the human psychosphere - otherwise
known as the collective unconscious.
He also found a redacted unanimous vote from
the O5 Council and Ethics Committee, as well
as a redacted series of directives sent out
to Senior Staff and Site Directors, which
caused a wave of suicides and resignations.
During his search, Pietro also discovered
a second series of directives sent out to
the remaining Site Directors and Senior Staff,
including the phrase “Harden your heart.”
These directives are known to some as “The
Cure.”
While Pietro didn’t have the context to
put all this together yet, these are more
vital clues to what happened.
The PNEUMA Project is what incited the Foundation’s
motivation to destroy humanity - killing off
humans is actually secondary to eliminating
something hiding else that’s hiding within
the human psychosphere - again that’s the
collective unconsciousness of all humans.
The O5 Council and the Ethics Committee were
unanimous in their approval of this project,
which was like deciding to burn down a house
to kill the inhabitant inside, except in this
scenario, humanity is the house.
So who or what exactly is the inhabitant?
You’ll find that out soon.
The next thing Pietro knew, he was sitting
half way across the country, with no memory
of the previous three months.
He was also carrying a briefcase with no knowledge
of what was inside except that it was“not
round.”
He also had a strange compulsion to deliver
the briefcase to SCP - 579, for reasons he
didn’t fully understand, but he hoped that
doing so would lead him to some answers.
Pietro may not have known what he was holding,
but we do.
The clue here is “not round” - which is
the only confirmed fact about SCP - 055, otherwise
known as The Anti-Meme.
This is an SCP with the primary anomalous
property of literally being unknowable.
People who observe it forget what they observed,
and have no memory of even looking at 055
in the first place.
This is why the briefcase was able to act
as Pietro’s personal “Skip” button.
Pietro was physically covering the distance
he traveled, but every time he opened the
briefcase and looked at SCP-055, he forgot
that period of time, making it seem as though
he simply skipped forwards.
The thing he was skipping towards, SCP - 579,
is an equally mysterious and highly dangerous
SCP contained within Site-62C.
Nobody even really knows what 579 is, only
that it’s an anomaly so dangerous that the
entirety of Site-62C was built to contain
it.
So what’s so important about bringing these
two together?
That, and the vital importance of Pietro’s
final mission, will become clear very soon.
Pietro continued his journey with the briefcase,
encountering more horrors and countless deaths
upon the way.
He finally found some solace in coming across
a group of Global Occult Coalition soldiers
discussing the interrogation of a captured
member of Foundation staff named Samuel Ross.
Two quotes from Ross’ enigmatic speech are
of particular interest here.
The first, in response to the threat of torture,
was “Do what you want.
Once you realize you're not supposed to feel
pain, there's nothing to be afraid of anymore.”
The second, after witnessing the death of
his captors, was “Look what you've done
to yourselves.
I told you you wouldn't like it, didn't you?
That's why you hear your voice.
But you wanted to know so badly.
I really liked you guys, so I was trying to
be nice.
We're so kind to you, you know.
We fight in the light so you can die in the
dark...disgusting.”
Do these quotes sound a little familiar?
The first because, as Pietro himself recalled,
the MTF members getting stabbed earlier also
didn’t seem to feel pain.
The second, because describing people as “disgusting”
is an adjective favoured by another infamous
SCP...
SCP-682.
This brings us back to “The Cure” - the
document disseminated by the O5 Council, instructing
people to “Harden Their Hearts.”
Whatever the Foundation discovered in the
human psychosphere, it’s apparently the
cause of all pain, and hence, when the Foundation
discovered it, they were able to train themselves
out of pain.
And as for the SCP - 682 reference - This
is a being that despises life, and it’s
believed by some that the reason 682 holds
this belief is that it’s always known about
whatever the Foundation recently discovered
through Project PNEUMA.
Decrypted text logs in the Foundation files
confirm this in a documented exchange between
O5-1 and Tejani, the head of the Foundation
Ethics Committee.
In their conversation they confirm the existence
of The Cure - which deprived the personnel
of everything from pain to empathy - being
disseminated among staff prior to the massacre,
and of the Foundation’s sudden ideological
alignment with SCP - 682.
And they had found something else too, referred
to simply as IT . Whatever IT was, it was
the reason Foundation Command decided to wipe
out humanity.
But what is IT?
What could possibly be so bad it was worth
killing all of humanity?
Perhaps most surprising of all is that Pietro
ran into the creature’s physical manifestation,
and he barely even considered it - due to
being occupied by avoiding the attacks of
the statue like, mantis-armed “Blinkers.”
Pietro made an entry in his log though, describing
the strange entity and described it like “a
person stretched out… like the space around
them was stretched out, and they were being
stretched along with it…
Their body went from the ground up to the
clouds, and their jaw swung at right angles.
There were these gaps, as well, black gaps
in space around its body, like wings.”
Foundation staff were fighting it, shooting
at this strange entity but their weapons had
no effect.
This creature, this IT, is a being that inhabits
the human psychosphere - meaning it exists
within the minds of all humans on some level,
driving and manipulating them to mysterious
ends.
What can it do?
What does it want?
It seems that the only people who know are
the O5 Council and the Foundation Ethics Committee
who were privy to the PNEUMA report.
But whatever it was they saw, they believed
it was worth killing off all of humanity just
to stop it.
As indicated by the unanimous vote from the
Ethics Committee, omnicide was a more ethical
choice compared to the alternative.
The influence of IT was also likely what gave
Pietro the strong, subconscious desire to
unite the briefcase containing SCP - 055 with
SCP - 579 - even at the cost of his own life.
This brings us to our final questions:
Why was it so important to unite SCP - 055
and SCP- 579, and what did this act serve
to achieve?
As Pietro, wounded by the Blinkers and lingering
on the edge of death, finally delivered the
briefcase into 579’s containment chamber,
he acknowledged the fact that he was no hero.
But that’s where Pietro was wrong.
After the destruction of SCP - 2000, Pietro
was in control of one of the only remaining
ways to save the world.
The combination of the anomalous effects of
055 and 579, as laid out in Roget’s Proposal
and the article for SCP - 2998, is the Foundation’s
ultimate trump card for preventing an XK-Class
end of the world scenario.
If the two are united during said scenario,
the universe resets to a time before the XK
Class scenario began, and prevents it from
happening.
In this case, Pietro uniting the two created
a new reality where the PNEUMA Project was
never launched, and IT was never discovered
- thereby averting the apocalypse.
The corpse of poor dead Pietro and the highly
damaged SCP - 5000 suit he wore were the only
evidence that this alternate reality ever
existed.
This means that the collaboration between
Pietro Wilson and the suit he just happened
to stumble upon quite literally saved the
universe as we know it from a Foundation that
had gone rogue.
In this regard, he’s one of the greatest
heroes the universe has ever known, even if
his actions weren’t entirely his own.
After all, he got a helping hand from the
suit, and another from IT - who still lurks
in all our minds, mercifully undiscovered,
to this day.
What was IT’s grand plan or purpose that
triggered all the madness?
Anyone who ever knew for sure resides in a
universe that no longer exists, and we can
only hope that a history that never happened
is somehow unable to repeat itself in ours.
And remember, check out our previous videos
on SCP - 5000 - The Suit to enjoy the epic
saga of Pietro Wilson’s journey through
a nightmare world with fresh eyes.